lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
obtener algo de práctica sobre cómo
saber si una variable aleatoria es una
variable binomial y para ello voy a
tomar algunos ejercicios que están en el
portal de lacan academy el primero dice
un gerente supervisa a once empleadas y
nueve empleados se necesitan tres de
estos empleados hombres o mujeres para
hacer un viaje de negocios así que el
gerente mete los 20 nombres en un
sombrero y los elige de manera aleatoria
sea x el número de empleadas elegidas ok
entonces el gerente va a ser tres
extracciones podemos llamar a cada una
de estas extracciones como una ejecución
y en cada una de estas ejecuciones
tendremos un éxito si el nombre que
aparece es femenino y justo x es el
número de nombres femeninos que
obtenemos después de estas tres
ejecuciones
es x una variable binomial especifica tu
respuesta así que pausa el vídeo e
intenta trabajarlo por tu cuenta
ok vamos a trabajarlo juntos la opción a
10 en cada ejecución no se puede
clasificar como éxito o fracaso por lo
tanto x no es una variable binomial
estoy en desacuerdo con esto que de
ejecución si se puede clasificar como
éxito o fracaso ya que la persona que
eligen es mujer o no lo es como dijimos
x mide el número de empleadas elegidas
por lo que cada nombre que extraigan del
sombrero que corresponda a una empleada
será un éxito así que cada ejecución si
se puede clasificar como éxito o como un
fracaso por lo tanto voy a eliminar esta
respuesta bien el inciso b dice no
tenemos un número fijo de ejecuciones
por lo tanto x no es una variable
binomial si tenemos un número fijo de
ejecuciones vamos a hacer tres
extracciones aquí lo dice ya que se
tomarán tres nombres del sombrero así
que también voy a cancelar esta opción
bien el inciso se dice las ejecuciones
no son independientes por lo tanto x no
es una variable binomial
esto es bastante interesante porque
observan en la primera ejecución déjame
ponerlo aquí en la ejecución 1
la probabilidad de obtener un éxito es
la siguiente bueno observan vamos a
tener 9 + 11 son 20 nombres ok y de esos
20 nombres tenemos 11 nombres de mujer
por lo tanto la probabilidad de éxito es
de 11 sobre 20 ahora que pasan en la
ejecución 2 déjame escribirla
aquí cuál es la probabilidad de éxito
dado que tengamos éxito en la primera
ejecución tengamos éxito
ok en la ejecución 1 bueno esta
probabilidad va a ser de ahora tenemos
19 nombres entonces aquí hay 19 de ellos
y si tuvimos éxito en la ejecución 1
vamos a tener solamente 10 nombres de
empleadas por lo tanto aquí hay un 10
aquí hay una gran diferencia porque si
no tuvimos éxito en la primera ejecución
significa que tendríamos todavía 11
nombres de mujeres en 19 nombres que hay
en el sombrero por lo tanto tu
probabilidad cambia según el resultado
anterior lo que quiere decir que las
ejecuciones no son independientes y por
lo tanto x no es una variable binomial
así que esta es la respuesta correcta y
por lo tanto voy a seleccionar la las
ejecuciones no son independientes por lo
tanto x no es una variable binomial para
tener una variable binomial necesitamos
que cada ejecuciones sea independiente
de las demás y voy a cancelar el último
inciso porque dicen x cumple todas las
condiciones para hacer una variable
binomial por lo tanto x tiene una
distribución binomial eso no es cierto
porque como ya vimos x no tiene
ejecuciones independientes
bien hagamos otro ejemplo aquí tengo
varios ejemplos y también tengo escritas
las condiciones que debe de cumplir
una variable aleatoria binomial una vez
más pausa el vídeo y observa
cuidadosamente los ejemplos y las
variables aleatorias definidas acá
arriba y piensa si cumplen o no las
condiciones que tenemos acá abajo bien
así que veamos la primera en un juego
que involucra una baraja estándar de 52
cartas un individuo reparte al azar
siete cartas sin reemplazo sea que igual
al número de aces repartidos si
recuerdas el vídeo de introducción a las
variables binomial es teníamos un
problema similar si hacemos este
escenario sin reemplazo la probabilidad
de obtener un as en una ejecución dada
donde cada ejecución significa sacar una
carta del mazo esta ejecución será
dependiente de lo que haya pasado en las
ejecuciones anteriores
que si tienes un as en una ejecución en
la siguiente ejecución tendrás menos
aces en el mazo así que déjame
escribirlo en este escenario los casos
son no independientes no independientes
ahora el otro caso donde tomabas una
carta y la regresaba al mazo es decir
con reemplazo en este caso si teníamos
casos independientes y teníamos una
variable binomial la probabilidad de
obtener un as en cada extracción era la
misma pero cuando tomamos las
extracciones sin reemplazo entonces los
casos son no independientes y por lo
tanto ésta no es binomial déjame ponerlo
ésta
es binomial
bien el segundo ejemplo dice 60% de una
especie de tomate sobrevive al
trasplantarse del semillero a la tierra
elizabeth tras plantas 16 plántulas de
este tomate además suponemos que la
sobrevivencia de cada planta es
independiente de las otras se hace igual
al número de plantas que sobreviven bien
veamos las condiciones para tener una
variable binomial el resultado de cada
ejecución se puede clasificar como éxito
o fracaso en este caso cada ejecución es
una de las plantas las de tomate tenemos
16 ejecuciones y un éxito será cuando la
planta sobreviva y un fracaso será si
muere por lo tanto cumplimos esta
condición bien de lujo cada ejecución es
independiente de las otras esto nos lo
dicen
además suponemos que la sobrevivencia de
cada planta es independiente de las
otras es decir que la sobrevivencia de
una planta es independiente decir la
otra planta sobrevive
por lo tanto cumplimos también esta
condición bien hay un número fijo de
ejecuciones bueno si tenemos 16 de ellas
por lo tanto también cumplimos está la
probabilidad pep de obtener un éxito en
cada ejecución es constante
también aquí tenemos el 60 por ciento de
probabilidad de sobrevivencia de cada
una de las plantas de semillero a la
tierra por lo tanto cumple todas estas
condiciones y ya puedo decir que este
segundo ejemplo se trata de una variable
binomial muy bien ahora veamos este
tercer ejemplo dice en un juego de azar
un turno consiste en que un jugador se
mantenga tirando un par de dados de seis
caras hasta que logre un doble es decir
dos caras iguales o sea x igual al
número de tiros por turno a ver si te
mantienes tirando los datos hasta
obtener un doble esto es lo que me salta
a la vista
no tenemos un número fijo de intentos no
hay un número fijo de ejecuciones déjame
notarlo no hay un número fijo de
ejecuciones puedes decir que cada
ejecución es un tiro de dados cada éxito
es obtener un par tiene una probabilidad
constante y obtener o no un doble es
independiente del tiro anterior así que
observa cumple todas las demás pero no
cumplen que hay un número fijo de
ejecuciones puede que en un turno me
tires el dado 20 veces o 200 veces o
cuántas veces sean hasta que obtengas un
doble y por lo tanto podemos concluir
que esta variable no es binomial
y hemos acabado